Recognizing patterns and
applying them in new situations.
Maybe two key features
of language and thought,
but what happens when the patterns wrong?
Last time I pulled out a critter
you've never seen before, uh,
Schwab and I think we agreed that we'd
immediately know what to say if I had
five or six of them,
but that's not thanks to the chuffed so
much as it is to our understanding of
plurals.
There's a paradigm for plurals in English
and it works for words big and small,
short and long,
so we have reason to be pretty confident
that this is just how plurals work in
English.
Then eventually we run into some
word that doesn't fit the paradigm.
We've abstracted and analogize
this general idea about plurals,
but its inadequacy is
staring us in the face.
This roadblock is not just a problem
for the grammar of English plurals.
If you ever had to fight your way through
some basic logic before you noticed
that we use general statements like all
this or every that to draw conclusions.
But just like with mice and alumni,
we're always at risk of running smack
into something that doesn't fit with the
general statement. We've worked so
hard to abstract and apply by analogy.
If you were living in the 17 hundreds
and your name where David Hume,
you would have pushed
this point very hard.
Wondering why from this experience we
form any conclusion beyond those past
instances of which we have had experience.
This gets called the problem of
induction and it asks us frankly,
why we should have predicted that the
plural of mouse would be mouses just
because the plurals of other
words and in in s of course,
if I'm learning English,
this seems like a fairly trivial event.
I note the exception. I hope that I
remember it next time and I move on,
but not all failed.
Applications of paradigms are this Mundane
Nassim Nicholas Taleb uses the
metaphor of the Black Swan.
Swans are white,
not black or so Europeans thought until
British ornithologists John Latham
stumbled across real life,
black swans in Australia,
black swan has since become a mascot
for rare events that have a surprisingly
huge impact.
These abnormalities drag us
has obvious after the fact,
just as obvious as it is to an English
speaker that mice is the plural of mouse
and to modern avian enthusiasts
that not all swans are white.
We can of course incorporate this new
information and maybe even be little
smarter with our paradigm by
hedging against big unknowns.
But can we go the other way?
Let's turn to plurals just one more time.
Children might get corrected
for saying mouses. Sure,
and they might step in line,
but at some point,
English speaking children applied
this same paradigm incorrectly,
but instead of incorporating
the correction,
they grew up to overturn old norms.
Sometimes we simplify.
Other times we preserve the irregularity
and there's even room for creativity.
As brand new patterns emerge
as we learn about language and thought
and use thought and language to learn.
Exceptions to the rule can give us some
use for feedback about the patterns we
think we see.